joining me right here on the Rich Eisen
show is the man who kicks off the day on
peacock every single day and then wraps
it up on NBC Sports on peacock every day
uh I said that we were the Florio
burrito but somebody called in uh Chris
Brockman and called it the it's the
Florio flout that's what it is okay with
The Dan Patrick Show this show and
brother for another in between and the
man himself Mike Florio joining me here
on the richen show how are you Mike so
wait we're the tortilla shell is that
how that works well you know what
whatever it's delicious it doesn't
matter it's just delicious that's all
that salsa it's scrumptious and it's a
it's a delectable treat is basically
what I'm saying doesn't matter that
works uh okay let's get into it there's
so much to discuss um and I I basically
said that uh it sounds fine about Dak
right now that he's already on the
menend he already had surgery and there
was a top-notch specialist who worked on
him but this guy's on the franchise tag
and I'm wondering if this is going to
change the way players View you playing
on this uh tag anymore after yesterday
Mike well look it's always part of the
risk that you take Rich when you wait
and watch and wonder whether or not
you're going to get the long-term deal
when you say no to the deal that's on
the table and you decide to push forward
when you you are willing to bet on
yourself one of the things you're
betting on is that there isn't going to
be a catastrophic injury and dax's
position has always been I've made
plenty of money off the field and he
does make plenty of money off the field
he's got insurance that protects him
against a career- ending injury not that
this is career ending and he's getting
31.4 million this year no matter what
where it becomes fascinating after the
season ends and the window opens on
another long-term deal between the
Cowboys and Prescott another multi-year
deal beyond the four-year deal he did as
a rookie will they sign him to something
that covers more than one season if they
don't by late February will they apply
the franchise tag again 37.68 million
the second time by rule and if the Cap's
only 175 next year that's 21.5% of the
cap devoted to a guy that you don't even
know he's going to be healthy come week
one and if they don't use the tag and
again they got to make that decision by
late February typically then he becomes
a free agent and he hits the market and
I looked at the standings today and I
picked out five six teams that will be
looking for a quarterback and may be
willing to pay Dak Prescott more than
what the Cowboys would and take the the
risk that it's going to take some time
for him to be back to 100 % so this is
all going to hinge on his health to a
certain extent but if he's not healthy
the Cowboys are going to have to make a
very careful decision about how much to
invest and how to play this out and
whether or not ultimately to use the
franchise tag and dak's position has
always been that this is just business
and he never gives in to whatever the
Cowboys want him to take and and we're
going to go through that again and I
think the stakes are going to be higher
than ever come February well walk me
through that list Mike because again I
know we're talking about uh obviously
next off season and there's a playing
season that is uh one of the most unique
playing seasons ever and we'll get to
that in a second but the reason why I
want to bring that out because it does
play uh into the way that uh that list
uh is created is is affected by wins and
losses that are happening right now um
and I'm wondering if Atlanta's on that
list now that they are clearly going to
start from scratch Dan Quinn and Thomas
demitro the coach and general manager
which we haven't discussed because we
were focused on the Lakers Sunday Night
Football and the stack injury in our
first segment uh they were both fired
after an 0 and five start cemented by I
love him I love the matchell I love Matt
Ryan you know uh but that interception
in the end zone that helped seal the
Fate yesterday of both of these men uh
looked like something that you would
call out a rookie for Mike I'm wondering
what what your list looks like well Rich
you know how it goes every GM wants his
own coach every coach wants his own
quarterback you're gonna have a new GM
and a new head coach was it the right
that's the right way to do it I I don't
like having the coach and the GM on
different tracks so they get a new GM a
new head coach and then the question
becomes is Matt Ryan the quarterback
that the Falcons need and if Dak
prescot's available depending upon who
the GM and the coach may be that's the
team that I have on my list the other
teams that I've got scribbl down here
the Jets are a possibility depending
upon whether to what extent things get
blown up in New York and whether or not
want to stick with Sam darnold the
Broncos if they decide Drew lock just
isn't the guy and Drew Lock's had a hard
time staying healthy the Jaguars if
things get blown up there the Colts have
Philip Rivers on a one-year deal and I'm
fascinated by the prospect of Dak
Prescott going to Indianapolis the Lions
maybe hitting the reset button and
moving on for Matthew Stafford did
Giants if Daniel Jones runs out of time
and wouldn't that be something to have a
reunion between Dak and Jason Garrett
Washington we don't know where they're
going now with Dwayne H Haskins the
Eagles if they decide it's the end of
the road for Carson Wentz what about the
Saints if Drew Rees retires and they're
not ready to hand the ball to to tesm
Hill and they just think he's never
going to be the guy uh what if what if
uh the 49ers give up on Jimmy Garoppolo
and it looks like maybe they should
after yesterday although the injury had
something to do with his performance so
you know every year there's that cluster
of teams that whether it's coaching
changes or whether it's just
exasperation they they want another
quarterback and Dak is going to get
thrown into that mix if the Cowboys
don't find a way to keep him around it's
going to make a fascinating offseason if
if that ends up being the case Rich Mike
Florio here on the richen show and you
know the way it works you know uh
there's there's two way it works for a
coaching search um in the NFL uh one is
you hire corn Ferry and you tap you give
money to somebody to give you a list
that you should pretty much have in the
right-hand drawer yourself you know some
sort of head hunting firm that's that to
me is I I I would love to have uh a
business like I I'll I'll I'll give you
a list for whatever you know I mean the
the list is is is life in the NFL pretty
much you could have it that's one way to
do it and the other way to do it is to
basically uh have your own way uh of
conducting the search by blowing your
coach out because you're afraid
everybody else is going to get a head
start so we saw the Texans hired that
they're they they hired a a head hunter
who do you have for me for the next team
that might say we got to get in on this
because two teams now have already
gotten a head start on who the next
coaches Mike and Rich I think you're I
think you're right on the money because
does Arthur Blank who has been more than
patient with Dan Quinn and Thomas
demitro demitro was hired in 2008 does
he make this move now if the Texans
aren't already out there with corn Ferry
looking under every Rock and and in
every nook and cranny for the right
possible candidates to come in and maybe
squat on them unofficially before the
Falcons have a chance I mean look at the
Jets yeah look worst thing that's
happened to the Jets this year is the
Panthers because the Panthers are
proving you can rebuild and still live
in the house right it's not a rebuild
it's a remodel and that's what the
Panthers are doing they they're three
and two and you know what they could be
four- one they gave the Raiders
everything they could handle week one
and it's not like the Buccaneers
embarrassed them and they've held their
own and they are they are improving with
what they have and they've won three in
a row without Christian mcaffrey for
crying out loud and I just think that
makes it even worse for the Jets and I
don't know how sustainable it is with
these embarrassments week after week
after week and the question becomes is
it a reset is it new coach NGM is it
just new coach if Woody Johnson comes
back in the off season because he's no
longer the US ambassador to the UK does
he just get rid of everybody and start
over again and bring back Rex Ryan I'm
only partially kidding when I say that
wouldn't be a great story if he did
wouldn't that be wouldn't that be
awesome look look at where the Jets have
been since Rex was fired Rex was was
like Glory Days compared to where they
are right now well Mike you know it
depends on what your definition of the
word awesome is to be honest with you um
I have a very different definition wait
wait they got they got to the they got
the AFC Championship Game oh they did
twice or twice was it once then it went
downhill then is when that's he was
still he was there when it started going
downhill but and and just to just to con
continue connecting some dots to what
you just pointed out about how the
Panthers make make it look worse for the
Jets is because they are three and two
um and my first guest in the second hour
and Matt rule was a guy that the Jets
were going to hire but said uh we have
to tell you who you can hire and not on
your staff because he was too green too
green to figure that out on his own they
were concerned about handing Sam darnold
off to that guy instead they hire Adam
gase and then the now go-to receiver for
the Carolina Panthers is Robbie Anderson
who the Jets let walk so there's that
too Mike but don't get me started
essentially is what I'm
saying makes it even harder to keep
things going with the New York Jets and
and I think that what the the Texans did
last week really does light the fuse for
some of these other teams that are
wondering what in the hell are we going
to do let's go ahead and get started on
it and you know there's that mindset
Rich that we hear from time to time that
you shouldn't fire guys during the
season disrespect remember the Mike
McCarthy refrain from a couple of years
ago but I think once you know you're
gonna do it I I think the respectful
thing to do is drop the charade move on
don't be searching or trying to
unofficially search behind the coach's
back or the GM's back just rip the
Band-Aid off and move on and and and and
I respect a team that does that because
now O'Brien Quinn demitro they all have
a chance to use this time to to figure
out their next career move Mike Florio
here on the Rich Eisen show uh pro
football talk
uh live every single day starting off
NBC Sports on peacock and PFT PM ending
every single day and then in between a
kind phone call to the Rich Eisen show
so Mike um where do things currently
stand right now about a possibility of a
week 18 being added to a schedule the
Titans in the Bills game is kind of a a
fulcrum contest if it can go off right
now uh tomorrow night looks like it's
going to where does everything on this
front stand best you can tell it is
amazing as you were articulating the
word fulcrum I was thinking of the word
fulcrum but I also was thinking don't
try to say fulcrum because if you say it
wrong you're
fired but but anyway kudos to you for
articulating it properly and preserving
your job I you're right you know all the
moves yesterday that were made and it
was extensive surgery that had to be
performed just to bump Broncos Patriots
by a week seven games in all affected by
that one move and my understanding is
they've got a model uh on a computer in
New York where there's a game they have
to postpone press the button all the
options get get spit out of the machine
as to what you can do the problem is
once the by weeks are gone you can't do
anything unless you're can have a team
play two games in one week the by weeks
are the key to allowing this rearranging
we went from a simple rearrangement for
Steelers Titans to a much more
complicated rearrangement for Broncos
Patriots and if Titans bills can't be
play tomorrow night that's going to be
the first game of this 18th week
whenever it may be and and they're
they're waiting until they absolutely
positively have to before going to an
18th week because there's a concern
people are going to get complacent hey
we got an 18th week you know if we miss
a game so what no big deal we get a
second buy we'll play an extra game
later in the year it's not that easy
because all it takes is one team Rich to
have two games affected and then a week
18 doesn't work you need a week 19 and I
think that they're holding week 18 in
one back pocket and then like like week
19 is like the gun strapped to your
lower leg that you only go to in the
absolute you know gravest of emergency
and so that that's I think an 18 and a
19 are floating around out there uh and
then the question is when do you play
them I was on with Mad Dog last week and
he said something that upset me because
I wished I'd have thought of it yes you
just take week 17 and you make it week
18 and then you backfill week 17 with
your extra games so you don't have the
one seeds possibly being three weeks
between games which makes a ton of sense
and then that week 17 which becomes week
18 is still that 16 game Crescendo with
all games played in one day and we get
everything figured out so I feel like
that's going to happen it's after only
five weeks we are where we are there's
no way there's not going to be an
so uh let me just pull on that strand
here it's concerning to me because we're
inside the brain of our friend
Christopher kuso so um
so if you take week 17 and make it week
18 then thus week 17 is the makeup date
for a whole bunch of
teams um wouldn't that give a byee to a
whole bunch of other teams for week 18
that they could absolutely utilize uh to
their benefit uh when they're sitting
back and seeing if a week 17 game
clinches a spot for them in week 18 and
then they don't have to play anybody and
then they sit back and have two by weeks
for somebody prior to you know you know
what I mean like there's so many
unintended consequences just off the top
of my head that would make that an issue
but you know the bottom line you're
right you're you're absolutely right
this is reality if if the goal is to get
into 256 games it's just a question of
of which unintended consequence should
we embrace and say we we do what we have
to do in order to play all the games
exactly because again that that's the
point here is that you know nothing is
normal anymore maybe for a very very
long time in our lives and the way that
we're looking at this I mean the NBA
just finished up for for crying out loud
uh on October 11th you know and then
there they they may not play and start
uh a regular season in the manner in
which we're used to it for another two
years you know and then the NFL forget a
combined draft I can't even imagine what
hell that's going on right now so I
guess anything goes uh what about the
idea of just hitting a pause button on
the entire season to make sure that
everybody gets back to the spot uh that
that we enjoyed for the first three
weeks of this campaign you know we were
talking about that yesterday during our
our just planning sessions for last
night's football night in America and
the problem with pressing the pause
button what do you do with the players
while you're on pause how do you keep
them in in football shape if all the
facilities are shut down for two weeks
and how do you prevent Tom Brady from
taking a group of teammates to a high
school field in Tampa and doing what the
Titans did doing what Brady did
throughout the off season even after the
NFL players Association strongly
encouraged all players to stop it until
training camp opens so I don't know that
the pause is the issue I continue to be
a firm believer in the home market
bubble because the NFL's current
protocol is premised on accepting Rich
the a that people are going to catch it
in the community and our goal is to
intercept those Folks by having them
test positive and ensure that until you
get the positive result we're practicing
the kind of of procedures in the
building that keep it from spreading if
you do a home market bubble and if you
can pull off a home market bubble and
everyone's staying in a hotel and this
would require negotiations between the
league and the union that's one of the
reasons why I think it hasn't happened
because the NFL doesn't want to make a
concession to the union and the union
doesn't want to agree to an
unprecedented restriction on the ability
of these guys to live their lives and be
with their families and live in a hotel
for three months but I think that's the
only way that you fix it and I had a GM
point out to me yesterday that here's
what's goingon to have to happen players
are gonna have to start losing game
checks by games that are postponed or
cancelled and can't be made up and once
that starts to occur then that's when
they'll say let's just go stay in a
hotel for the rest of the year because
we're losing real money with these games
away and and unfortunate it's going to
take that before it happens because it's
something they should all just agree to
and do now to avoid games being lost but
that's the thought games are going to
have to be lost before the players and
the league decide to work out some kind
of a deal to put everyone in a hotel for
the rest of the season before we send
Mike Florio into the rest of his day to
prepare for PFT PM uh to wrap up the uh
the day here on NBC Sports on peacock
ask him the poll question Christopher
that you can vote on at Rich Eisen show
right right now yourselves yeah Mike
what was the most impressive win from
yesterday Cowboys Dolphins Raiders
Seahawks you I think it was the the
Raiders uh because the Chiefs that had
that air of invincibility around them
they hadn't lost a game since last
November to go into Kansas City to have
a a plan on defense and I talked to Jeff
Heath who had an interception Y St of
Patrick HS about what they did I mean
they accept they're going to have to
deal with longer plays they're going to
have to cover their guys a little bit
longer and you do just have to realize
and I say this all the time the Chiefs
are like a basketball team that's going
to go on an 18-2 run just just deal with
that you know what's gonna happen the
rest of the game you try to overcome
that and that's what the Raiders did and
Derek
Carr exasperated at times by his refusal
to throw the ball down the field when
the shots are there he threw it down the
field yesterday and if they can contain
that they had this week off and then
they've got the Buccaneers and Tom Brady
coming to town if he will keep doing
that that could be the thing that really
gives the Raiders a chance to to contend
with and maybe compete with the Chiefs
in that division which would be
something if they could pull it off all
right Mike uh who's on PFT PM is there
anything you want to promote to keep
everybody uh uh having their wet their
beak a little bit for what's on the
backend Monday Mondays are a big big day
where we look back on everything that
went right everything that went wrong
sharen Williams joins me and that one
hour just flies by hopefully it flies by
for the folks who are watching but it
definitely flies by for us and we're
looking forward to to getting ready
everybody for Monday night the Saints
Chargers and also looking back on
everything that happen throughout the
course of the day so uh yeah that's
coming that's coming I still I still
would prefer to just do three hours at
once but I kind of like having that one
hour at the end of the day because there
have been a lot of days in in recent
weeks where uh that extra hour comes in
handy because a lot of things happen
between 9:00 am and 5 PM well my problem
is that it's always five o'l somewhere
for me during this pandemic um and so on
at 5 Eastern so uh best of luck to you
on that sir and uh excellent work as
always and love uh being a part of this
lineup that you start and finish every
single day thanks all right hey great
talking to you rich thanks look back at
you that's Mike Florio check out pfpm
later right here on NBC Sports on
peacock at 5 Eastern Time hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right
here